what I'm Jack what's up Zack I'm Corbin
I'm Jonah I'm Daniel and we and we're
hanging out with BuzzFeed today and
we're gonna play who's who think about
who posts the most selfies Daniel when
you take I barely know Sophie did you
take four posts I mean yeah but Jonah's
like that would like bugs okay that's if
it's inside like if there's a bug inside
like just put it down sighs don't save
[Music]
[Music]
this is how my fingers Jonas wakes up
he's ready I don't even know I feel like
I just find things to do you know I mean
where you're just like what else can I
do before I need to be downstairs
like you all talking all the time yeah
it depends on my mood right
I just feel like he's good at talking
I'll speak whenever Oberon can be a
radio you know this Jonah can actually
do it right like the weather forecast
what's up it's why don't we were hanging
out here with BuzzFeed today then they
had to pop it back in and then he came
back out onstage and finish the guy I
was not I'm more on a phone call that
he's a Twitter I'll go down my feet and
every pic I see jack is already liked it
every time it says like my deck every I
mean like oil my feet I always find that
I forget to like a post like I'll be
scrolling and I'll be like oh that's
sick
[Music]
[Music]
oh yeah by a baseball player though I
met this my favorite baseball player
actually I was very starstruck than I
met Davis with Taylor Swift backstage at
Jingle Ball at Madison Square Garden
green room smelled so good yeah she told
me to say hi to my family oh I'm Taylor
Swift says how are you doing that's the
question that's a loaded question I've
definitely heard cars do something but I
think I think I think Daniel I mean I'll
take it if you find someone who loves
your music - then there's nothing
different about a phone you know they
already like you I mean like regardless
entitle of someone and just comes down
to the person that's a good way to push
[Music]
never take advice from Zach why Thank
You subduing this devious things I give
the good advice for you to have fun in
life it's not always the best advice
thanks so much for watching this was
really fun and make sure to check out
our single what am I check it out number
one baby having to subscribe all that
[Music]